แต่ปีน้ำกด
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเรา
มีนักเรียน
11 คนใช่ไหมคะหนวันนี้ก็มามาไม่ครบ
ไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่าครู 2 คนเนี่ยหยุดนาน
นักเรียนครูไม่ดีครูไปดิครูขี้เกียจ
ครูมาแล้วครูมาแล้วให้โทรมาแล้วนะคะเวร
รีบมาแล้วก็ดูฟังภาษาไทยนะคะแล้วก็
คอมเม้นท์เช็คชื่อข้างล่างด้วยนะคะขอ
ราคาและเกรียน 11 คนมานะมานะน้องกดไลค์นะ
คะกดไลค์ให้ด้วยครูจะได้รู้มาครบ 11 คน
มั้ยใต้ค่ะนะคะครูเอ๋อยากได้สิบฆ่าคนกด
ไลค์
ได้นักเรียนต้องกดไลค์กดไลค์นะ
ห้าคนใช่อ่ะน้อยสุด 15 คนนะคะค่ะกดไลค์นะ
คะแล้วก็กดแชร์ให้เรานะคะพายค่ะมาแล้วก็
ข้างล่างเขียนแนะนำตัวฉันชื่ออะไรบอกด้วย
นะคะๆนะจะได้มาเป็นนักเรียนคนที่ 12
13  14 ของเรา
ธนธารแล้วอนาคตเราก็จะมี
40-50 คนใช่ไหมคะถ้าจำไม่ได้แล้ว
กูเอกก็จำไม่ได้ขอโทษ
มาฮ่าๆได้ค่ะก็วันนี้ค่ะครูหญิงเดี๋ยวครู
เอ๋คอร์ดคะกู a  Share  screen ก่อนได้
ค่ะครูเอ๋อันนี้ก็อันนี้อันนี้อะไรดีอัน
นี้แหละ
อันนี้เอาเคผู้หญิงมองเห็นไหมคะมองเห็น
ค่ะมองเห็นนะคะ
คุยโอเคเขียนตรงไหนดีเอ่ยผู้หญิงมองเห็น
นะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะผู้หญิงวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เว้นคุยเขียนได้ไหม
สักคู่ค่ะคุยเขาเปลี่ยนปากกา
วันพุธมีผู้หญิงเห็นแค่นี้นะ
อยู่ตรงไหนคะพี่ผู้หญิงขีดเส้นสีชมพูแค่
นี้ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะครูเองสักครู่นะผู้หญิง
กูเอกขยับก่อน
ได้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงแค่นี้ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
ได้ไหมตอนนี้คุณหญิงตรงนี้กูหญิงเห็นไหม
คะเห็นค่ะครุยวันนี้คุยขยายวันนี้วันพุธ
นะคะบ่อยคิด
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 ค่ะวันที่ 11
ราคา
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพตเท่าไหร่คะดีพ.ต.ต.
2565 ค่ะ
ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะอุ้ยดีคศ 2
022 ค่ะสอง 2 ผู้หญิงมองเห็นนะมองเห็น
ค่ะมองเห็นนะคะแต่กูเองไม่เห็นผู้หญิง
โอเคเห็นแล้วเห็นแล้วราคา
ผู้หญิงแล้ววันนี้น่ะวันพุธนะคะตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
16:00 น 6 นาทีค่ะกี่โมง 6 นาทีนะคะ
ไปค่ะ
4:06 เดี๋ยวคุยลบนะคะผู้หญิง -
ๆ - กลอนกูอีกลบก่อน Love ยางลบคู๋อุ้ย
ครูเอ๋
อะไรอ่ะถ้าไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไรกูเอใส่สีขาว
เลยแล้วกัน
โอเคจะได้ค้างหมดสีขาวนะคะหาวนี่ครูหญิง
วันนี้คุณเอ๋มีอันนี้ค่ะโง่อะไรคะครูเอ๋
แผนที่หากผู้หญิง
แผนที่ประเทศอะไร
แผนที่ประเทศไทย
นะคะอันนี้ผู้หญิงมองเห็นนะต้องเห็นค่ะ
โอเคอันนี้เป็นแผนที่ประเทศไทยผู้หญิงมอง
เห็น 100% ไหมคะผู้เห็นผู้หญิงไม่เห็นสี
เขียวอ่ะอันเนี่ย 100% ค่ะโอเค
คูเอกต้องเช็คผู้หญิงนะว่าเห็น
ทั้งหมดไหมนะคะเป็นแผนที่ประเทศไทยครู
หญิงครับประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีกี่ภาคคะทั่ว
ประเทศไทยมีทั้งหมด 6 ภาคค่ะมีทั้งหมดคบ
ภาคนะคะ 6 ค่านะคะมีภาคอะไรบ้างคะอันนี้
พักที่ 1 สีแดงจังๆได้ค่ะ 1 ภาคอะไรคะภาค
เหนือค่ะ 1 ภาคเหนือนะคะ
อ่ะ 2 คาดอะไรคะ
สองภาคอีสานค่ะสองข้างอีสานนะคะ
3 นะคะ
3 ภาคอะไรคะภาคกลางค่ะคะกลาง 4
คาดอะไรคะถ้าตะวันตกค่ะภาคตะวันตกข้า
ข้าอะไรคะอ่ะเมื่อตะวันออกค่ะภาคตะวันออก
นะคะ
6 ภาคอะไรคะถ้าใต้ค่ะทักใต้นะคะ
มีทั้งหมด 6  5 ผู้หญิงพูดอีก 1 ครั้งได้
ไหมคะเท่าไหร่ค่ะอ่ะ 1 ภาคอะไรคะภาคเหนือ
อะ 1 ภาคเหนือสองภาคอะไรคะภาคอีสานภาค
อีสาน
3 ภาคอะไรคะ
มาตรางคาดกลางนะคะ 4
ภาคอะไรคะถ้าจะวันตกข้างตะวันตกค่าภาค
อะไรคะถ้าจะวันออกทางตะวันออก 6 ภาคอะไร
คะถ้าขาดๆก็ 6 ภาคโอเคนะนักเรียนฟัง 2
ครั้งแล้ว
นะฮะให้เต็มไรเมาไม่เป็นไร
เข้าใจโอเคไม่เข้าใจโอเคผู้หญิงคะพักภาค
เหนือก็จะมีจังหวัดจังหวัดจังหวัดจังหวัด
จังหวัดใช่ไหมคะอะไรค่ะแล้วทั้งหมดกี่
จังหวัดคะมีทั้งกี่จังหวัดคะครูเอ๋ภาค
เหนือและเหนือเหรอ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8
9 จังหวัดค่ะกูภาคเหนือมี 9 จังหวัด
แล้ว 2 เนี่ยภาคอีสานค่ะมีกี่จังหวัดคะ
ครูเอ๋เฮ้ยอีสานมีครูให้ดูก่อนนะๆแต่
ถ้าอีสานมีทั้งหมด 20 จังหวัดค่ะ
20 จังหวัดมองไม่เห็นสีเขียวดีกว่า
20 จังหวัด 5 มาแล้ว 20 จังหวัดค่ะค่ะ
แล้วภาคที่ 3 ภาคกลางมีกี่จังหวัดคะภาค
กลางมี
22 จังหวัดค่ะงูภาคกลางมีงู
22 จังหวัดตอนนี้กูมีมากที่สุด
แล้วภาคที่ 4 ภาคตะวันตกมีกี่จังหวัดคะ
ครูเอ๋วันตกมี 1  2  3  4  5 จังหวัดค่ะ
คู่หญิงมีน้ออีกด้วยนะคะหน่อยนะมี 5
จังหวะแล้วภาคที่ 5 ภาคตะวันออกมีกี่
จังหวัดคะครูเอ๋ภาคตะวันออกมี 7 จังหวัด
ค่ะฝากแล้วก็สุดท้ายภาคที่อกภาคใต้มีกี่
จังหวัดพระครูเอ๋ป้ายมีอยู่นะเว้ยดูก่อน
เล็กๆ
14 จังหวัดค่ะ
งงกูเอ๋แล้วทางหมดประเทศไทยมีกี่จังหวัด
คะ
จังหวัดทั้งหมดในประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะไข่ค่ะ
จังหวัดทั้งหมดในประเทศไทยมีเฮบวกค่ะ
ไอคิวดีไม่ได้ตัวเองเดี๋ยวราคา
ก็บวช
20 เท่าไหร่คะ 29 โอเค
เก่งมาก
ๆคิวดีแล้วเราก็บวช
22 เท่าไหร่คะ
อ้า 1  51
เก่งมากแล้วก็ +  4
+  5  +  5
ไอ้คิวไม่ดีนะบวชตาไม่ดีอ่ะ +  5
เท่าไหร่คะครูหญิง
56 ค่ะครูเอ๋
56  56 ไปบวกที่นี่แอบ
+77 ก็
63 ค่ะเข้ากับ
63 เป็นมีอัค 63 อาโตมิ
63 นะเขว
โอเค
เอา 63 อ้าว
63 นะคะ
63 มาตรงนี้
บวกสิบสี่เท่าไหร่คะ
77 ค่ะครูเอ๋
77 จังหวัด
งั้นจังหวัดทั้งหมดในประเทศไทยมี 77
จังหวัดได้มี 77 จังหวัด
ไม่ต้องบอกนะจังหวัดอะไรไม่บอกไม่ต้อง
หรอกอ่ะถ้านักเรียนอยากรู้จังหวัดอะไรไป
ดูครูเอ๋กับครูอาตี้นะคะซีรีส์กังหวัด on
มีแต่แล้วลบนะคะลบใช้เวลาหน่อยค่าใช้จะลบ
ทุกอย่างจะหายหมด
โอเคเอก -
ๆขอ
ตัวเองลบออกใช่ไหมที่คุยเขียนตัวเลข 5  -
5 ก็
ตอนนี้นักเรียนก็รู้แล้วจังหวัดทางหมด
เนี่ยมี
77 ราคากะในประเทศไทยมีทั้งหมด 77
จังหวัดๆ 77 จังหวัดมหาสารคามค่ะผู้หญิง
ครูเอ๋
แว็กซ์มีประเทศไทยมี 77 จังหวัดใช่ไหมคะ
เราก็ตรงนี้อ่ะตรงนี้ของประเทศไทยเนี่ย
ตรงไหนคะครูเอ๋พรุ่งนี้
จริงๆตรงนี้ทั้งหมดแถวนี้
ทั้งหมดที่เป็นสีฟ้าหรอคะคู๋ชาและทะเลตรง
นี้เป็นทะเลใช่ไหมคะค่ะทะเลตรงนี้เรียก
ว่าอะไรคะทะเลลงนี้เรียกว่าอ้าวไทยค่ะไง
คะอ้าวถ่ายตกตรงนี้ตรงนี้ 5
อ้าวไทยนะคะแล้วทะเลตรงนี้นะคะเรียกว่า
อะไรคะทะเลอะไรเรียกว่าทะเลอันดามันโอ้ว
เก่งมากคุยถึง
ผู้ชมกัน 2 คนน่ะ
ฉันก็รู้
จะคุยอะไรนะคะผู้หญิงก็เลยรู้ไงคะนัก
เรียนรู้ครูหญิงรู้
ครูเอกเลยนะคะจะบอกประเทศไทยหนักมีทะเลมี
ที่พักใต้เนาะตรงภาคใต้น่ะก็มีทะเลเน่าไป
ทะเลอันดามัน
วู้แต่ว่าถ้าพลาดพาดภาคกลางก็ทะเลอ่าวไทย
ภาคตะวันออกทะเลอ่าวไทยฮะตะวันตก
แต่ไม่มีทะเลมีสิคะผู้ใหญ่นี่ไงนายไม่มี
ผู้หญิงไม่มีประเทศไทยภาคตะวันตกไม่มี
ทะเลหัวหินเนี่ยครูเอ๋
ใช่ๆ
ตัวเองก็ผู้หญิงดูตามสีเลยค่ะเนี่ยภาค
บันทึกตบ
คู๋กูเองคิดอันนี้คิดตรงนี้
ขอโทษกูเอกคิดตรงนั้น Myanmar และนี่คือ
ผู้หญิงคิตรงนี้ค่ะตรง Play ภาคตะวันตก
ทะเลเอา
ตัวเอง
หัวหินสระโกรธครูเอ๋นะคะหัวหินขอโทษ
หัวหินค่ะคอร์ดขอโทษประจวบขอโทษชุมพรนะคะ
ขอโทษเพชรบุรีนะคะขอโทษเพชรบุรี
มีมีมีขอโทษค่ะขอโทษเอาใหม่เอาใหม่ภาค
กลางเนี่ยมีทะเลอ่าวไทย
ภาคตะวันออกมีทะเลอะไรคะทะเลอ่าวไทยค่ะ
พฤติกรรมนะติดอ่ะเนาะติดอ่ะติดกับทะเล
อ่าวไทยแล้วบอกว่าภาคตะวันออกมีทะเลทะเล
เอาไทยไก่ค่ะแล้วก็พักตะวันตกก็มีทะเล
อ้าวไทยไม่มีทะเลมีทะเล
มีข่าวไทยแล้วก็ทะเล
อันดามันฮุ้ยภาคใต้มีทะเล 2 ทะเลเลยเฮ้ย
มีฝั่งฤทธิ์ติดทะเลอ่าวไทยแล้วก็ติดทะเล
อันดามัน
[เพลง]
ชอบภาคใต้ใส่ค่ะนะคะอาผู้หญิงกูเองมีคำ
ถามต่อไปอ่าประเทศไทยมีเกาะไหมคะนี่ค่า
ประเทศไทยมีเกาะสินค้าคู่เอกเกาะนิดหน่อย
หรือมีเกาะมากๆมีเกาะมากๆค่ะครูอนให้มี
เกาะมากเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋เช็คผู้หญิงรู้จัก
เกาะไหม
คิดว่าครูเอ๋ถามครูหญิงว่ามีเกาะเท่าไหร่
ไว้ถามอันนั้นไว้สาวกูอีก
เดี๋ยวกูเอกจะหน้ากลมวงกลมนะคะที่เกาะอ่า
แล้วก็คุยหญิงบอกนักเรียนเกาะชื่ออะไรได้
ค่ะโอเคมั๊ยโอโอเคค่ะถ้าครูหญิงไม่รู้คู่
หญิงก็ยอมแพ้นะคะยอมแพ้
ยอมแพ้โอเคเอาง่ายๆก่อนครับผู้หญิงค่ะเอา
กล่องใหญ่ๆเนาะเกาะเล็กๆไม่เอาอ่ะตรงนี้
ค่ะ
หนู
นะคะถ้าก็ก็อะไรคะ
ครูหญิงรู้ค่ะครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคุณ
ทาชิยกมือคุณถ้าและที่ไม่ได้ค่ะครูหญิง
บอกค่ะคุณจอห์นก็ยกมือไม่เอาเขื่อนจะเอา
ค่ะครูหญิงอ่ะพูดไม่ได้ค่ะนักเรียนครู
หญิงบอกค่ะพี่อยากจะบอกใช่ไหมคะใครฝาก
เกาะอะไรคะผู้หญิงเกาะภูเก็ตค่ะครูเอ๋
ชื่อภูเก็ตเกาะภูเก็ตภูเก็ต
เจ๊เก่งว่า
เกาะภูเก็ตนิใหญ่เอ๋สน
[เพลง]
เกาะนักเรียนดูไม่เป็นดู
เก๋ต้องอ่ะวัดใหม่
เป็นเกาะเป็นเกาะแล้วนะเกาะที่ 1 เกาะ
ภูเก็ตผู้หญิงเอาไว้อัดใกล้ๆภูเก็ตเกาะ
อนงค์ไหนคะอ๋ออ่อนและทะเลอ่าวไทยหรอเกาะ
อารีย์อ่าวไทยตอนนี้เอาพัดตายก่อนนะพัก
ตายอ้ะ
เกาะอะไรคะเกาะสมุยไหมคะ
เย้ Thing เก่งมากค่ะเก่งมากเกาะสมุยนะคะ
ซื้อเกาะสมุยอ่ะเอาไปเล็กๆก่อนค่ะนัก
เรียนทำไมนักเรียนบ่เฮ้ยผมก็รู้
ทำไมนักเรียนรู้นักเรียนไม่ใช่คนไทยค่ะ
ไม่รู้นักเรียนชอบเกาะสมุยชอบเกาะภูเก็ต
ราคา
ก็ตกอีกไหมค่ะมากผู้หญิง
เมื่อ
อุ้ย
อยู่ตรงนี้ตอบที่ 3
เกาะอะไรคะอ่ะและก็ช้างไหมคะเกาะช้าง
เกาะช้าง
เก่งมาก
นะตัวเอนนักเรียนบอกนักเรียนรู้เหมือนกัน
ๆอันไหนอีกอันไหนอีกเกาะหนึ่งแล้วกันกู
แอบชอบอันนี้กูเองชอบอ๋อ
ก็ก็อะไรคะ
ก็กูดหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงทำไมรู้ผู้หญิงรู้เกาะช้างเกาะกูด
ใกล้ๆกันแล้วก็มีเกาะกูดเกาะเหลายาเกาะ
นามเกาะไม้สิ
ไม่รู้จักแล้วค่ะอยู่ใกล้กันนะนะคะ
โอเคประเทศไทยก็มีเกาะเนาะอีกหรอกถ้าเยอะ
นะคะมิเกาะโอ
และเที่ยงที่ทะเลใช่มั้ยพูดเอ๋หน้ากูเอก
จะทำให้ใหญ่ขึ้นยังไงเวียนหัว
ที่นี้มีเกาะแล้วมี
ผู้หญิงอ้าประเทศไทยมี 6 ภาคค่ะ
ภาคไหนหนาว
หนาวหนาว
มากอ่ะเคยไปเท่าไหร่อ่ะช่วยเท่าไหร่คะ
000 องศาเซลเซียสเลยเหรอคะเคยไม่ใช่ไหม
หนูไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไหมหนาวที่สุด
วุ้ย
ผิดก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันกูเองเป็นนักหนาว
โว้ยแต่ว่าประเทศ
be042  0 มีศูนย์ผมอาจจะ 1 วันขึ้นค่ะกู
เขาได้ที่ภูเขาโอเคไม่เป็นไรคูเอกจะถาม
ผู้หญิงว่า
คาดไหนอาจจะมี 1 ภาค 2 ภาคโอเคนะคะภาคไหน
ในประเทศไทย
หนาว
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าชาติเหนือ
ง่าแพ็คเหนืออันนี้นะคะพระอะภาคเหนือ
หนาวนะคะหน้าพรรคเดียวหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเฮ้ยอีสาน
หนาวต้องอ่านอีสานข้างบนเนาะอีสานตรงนิ
สถาน
อีสานตรงนี้นาหลาวมากนะคะบอกสูญญาต่อ
ไปใช่
มีฟิล์มเอ๊ะอะไรอ่ะถาม
ผู้หญิงคะอะไรคะครูเอ๋ถ้าไหนพรรคไหน
ร้องร้อนร้อนๆ
มาก
คาดกลางกัน
ไว้เธอ
ไม่ใช่หรอไม่ใช่
5 ตท่าตะวันภาคตะวันออกใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่
[เพลง]
ถ้าตะวันตก
ต้องตรงนั้นเลยจังหวัดนี้ตรงนี้เลยนะคะ
ที่ผู้หญิงชี้เลยเหรอคะ
กาญจนบุรี
ร้อนมากระหาเท่าไหร่ครูเอ๋เอ๋ร้อน
1  2 องศาแบบโอเคร้อนมากอุณหภูมินะ 42
องศาเซลเซียสโอเคค่ะ
เอ่อ
อีสานภาคอีสานตรงนี้ก็ร้อนตอนหอมร้อน
เหมือนกันนะคะงั้นช่วยคะถ้าอีสานเนี่ยภาค
อีสานข้างบนหนาวให้ข้างบนหนาวข้างล่าง
ร้อนขอ
เปิดนะๆๆตรงนี้ก่อนรึ
ค่ะคุยมีคำถามอีกไหมมีมีผู้หญิงรู้ไหมมี
อะไรคะมีมีมี 1 จังหวัด 1 จังหวัดณ 1
จังหวัดเนี่ยจะมีฝนตก
ฝนตกคุยไว้ตรงนี้ละกันนักเรียนจะได้เห็น
มีฝาน็อค 10 บาท
พูดไม่มีม่ค่ะเมฆแล้วก็
ฝนตกราคา
ฝนตกเนี่ย 8 เดือน
มา 1 ปีนะมี 12 เดือนฝนตก 8 เดือนใช่
ประเทศไทยเหรอคะครูเอ๋ประเทศไทยประเทศไทย
ผู้หญิงรู้มั้ยจังหวัดเนี้ยที่ฝนตก 8
เดือนอยู่ภาคอะไร
ผู้หญิงนะคิดว่านะคะคุณเอ๋เอ๋ภาคอีสาน
เนี่ยไม่ใช่ทำไมอ่ะไอ้สําร้อนไงคนไทยได้
มีนะหนาวหนาวร้อน
หือคุยคิดว่าคิดว่าภาคอะไรคะถ้าหากใต้ไหม
คะครูเอ๋ภาคใต้โอ้ยยเออเก่งเว้ยผู้หญิง
เอาภาคใต้มีทะเลทะเลสองฝั่งไงไม่คิดคนตก
ไอ้คิวดิ
จังหวัดอะไรรู้ไหมคะ
ภูเก็ตไหมคะแตกอ้าว
ไม่ใช่ให้คิดใหม่คิดใหม่
อีก
สงขลา
สงขลาแอดได้อีก 1 ครั้ง
ษณา
อะไรนะทำงา
[เพลง]
แล้วจังหวัดอะไรคะครูเอ๋จังหวัดระนอง
ออกอุ้ยอยู่ใกล้ๆภูเก็ตเนาะเราดูอ่ะนะ
ครูหญิงตอบภูเก็ตพังงา
อ่านแต่ไม่ตอบระนอง
ไปสงขลาสงขลาอยู่แถวไหนอ่ะ
ล่างมาหาพังงาอยู่ตรงนี้เหรอคะครูเอ๋ๆ
พังงาอยู่ภูเก็ตพังงาระนอง
ทำไมพูดไม่ตอบละน้องทำไม
จังหวัดเอส
ฝนจังหวัดระนองฝนตกมากๆเหรอคะวันตก 8
เดือน
xd แล้วผู้หญิงชอบ
มีฝนตกฝนตกน่ะ 8 เดือนนะคะ
เดี๋ยวลบอันนี้ก่อนได้ค่ะครูและมีสำนัก
ใต้ภาคใต้น่ะไม่หนาวหนาวๆนิดหน่อยแต่มีฝน
ตกฝนตกฝนตกมากๆนะคะแล้วก็ร้อนกับฝนตกเหรอ
คะเสือใต้นายแบบแต่ว่าภาคตะวันออกก็ร้อน
แต่มีลม
มีลมจากทะเลทะเลนะมีลมเข้า
ท่ากร่างก็มีลมลมเข้าอันนี้ก็มีลม
ลม
ร้อนจะมีลมค่ะ
[เพลง]
ร้อนแต่ว่ามีลมใช่มั้ยมีลมไม่มีลมไหมเห็น
ลมไหมที่ลมเวลาลมพัด
ต้องมีไปอะพัดผู้หญิงพัชก็ได้ค่ะคู๋โอเค
มั๊ยอันนี้มีเสียงด้วยค่ะครูเอ๋
ลง
งั้นครูเอ๋บอกว่าภาคตะวันตกใช่ไหม
กาญจนบุรีตรงนี้เนี่ยร้อนมากๆคือไม่มีลม
เหรอคะอยู่
ตรงนี้มีภูเขา
[เพลง]
มีภูเขาภูเขามากๆ
กาญจนบุตรอยู่ข้างในภูเขา
ลม
หน่อยก็เลยร้อนเข้าใจร้อนมากๆผู้หญิงรู๋
มีคำถามอีกอุ้ยมีคำถามอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋
ประเทศไทยใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็เราก็มีเพื่อน
บ้าน
เรามีเพื่อนบ้านนะคะ aku  A มีคำถามว่า
ภาคไหน
ภาคพักผ้าอะไรแล้วกันนะคะภาคอะไรที่มี
เพื่อนบ้านเป็นประเทศลาวหรอ
และก็
มุดผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเล่าไหนราคาลเน็ตลาว
อยู่ที่นี่
แต่อันนี้เรามั้ย
ใช่ R
มันก็ผ่านอีสานภาคเหนือ
เสน่ห์หอมภาคคุยภาคเหนือภาคอีสาน
[เพลง]
ใช้หาผู้หญิงกากบาททำไมอ่ะ
ค่ะพักเหนือกับข้างอีสานใช่ไหมคะภาคเหนือ
ภาคอีสาน
มีเพื่อนบ้าน
คือประเทศลาวนะคะ
เพื่อนบ้านก็คือติดประเทศไทยอ่ะติดประเทศ
ไทยนะคะแล้วก็ตรงนี้เราเรียกว่าชายแดนมี
ผู้ชายแดน
ได้ก็บอกชายแดนลาวน่ะชายแดนลาวติดกับภาค
เหนือติดกับข้างอีสานฉบับเป็นการเมืองชาย
แดนลาวติดเนื้อติดอีสานไทยราคา
กูหญิงอะไรคะ
คาดอะไรนะคะภาคอะไรมีชายแดนติดกับ
เมียนมาร์
คาดเหนือ
ฮาดตะวันตก 5 ชายข้าทำเองไหมคะอะไรนะคะ
ภาคใต้ด้วยไหมคะนิดหน่อยนะ
ก็พักเหนือนะคะภาคเหนือ
ภาคตะวันตกล็อคตรงนี้ชายแดนซ์หน้าไปทาง
ทิศใต้ชายแดนติดฝีแดงนะคะสีแดงอันนี้ถ่าย
แดนชายแดนติดกันนะคะ
ครูหญิงคะนะคะ
ภาค
ตะวันออกตะวันออกณชายแดนติดประเทศอะไร
ชายแดกอะภาคตะวันออกชายแดนติดประเทศ
กัมพูชาสะ
งา
ไอคิวดี
แล้วจำพูชามีชายแดนติดภาคอะไรของประเทศ
ไทย
กัมพูชามีชัยแดนติดภาคตะวันออก
ภาคอีสาน
ภาคอีสานนะคะๆนี้ชายแดนนะท่าน
ผู้หญิงคะอะไรคะคุณเองมีคำถามเยอะ
ประเทศมาเลเซียอ่ะ
มาเลเซีย
มาเลเซียมีชายแดนติดคาดอะไรของประเทศไทย
ต่อประเทศมาเลเซียมีชายแดนติดภาคใต้ค่ะ
ภาคใต้พรุ่งนี้เนาะจ่ายนั้นคือเส้นไทยแต่
ชายแดนไทยมาเลเซีย
แล้วภาคใต้มีชายแดนติดประเทศอะไรบ้างคะ
อาจารย์ใต้มีชายแดนติดประเทศ
มาเลเซีย
1 มาเลเซียแล้วก็พม่าค่ะเหมือนมานะครับ
เนียนมากเนาะพม่าหรือเมียนมากๆก็พูดเหม็น
มา
มาหากับพม่าบอกฉันเปลี่ยนแล้วเมียนมากค่ะ
ฉันเหมือนมานะคะโอเคค่ะอ่ะผู้หญิงคะคะ
คำถามสุดท้ายแม่น้ำมันสีฟ้า
แม่น้ำนะคะแม่น้ำ
แม่น้ำ
ใหญ่ที่สุด
อยู่ภาคอะไรคะใหญ่นะไม่ใช่ยาวนะยายหรอ
ใหญ่ๆอย่าภาคกลางภาคกลาง
ภาคกลางชื่ออะไรคะ
เจ้าพระยา
ไปค่ะ
แม่น้ำเจ้าพระยา
เจ้าพระยาค่ะพญาใหญ่ที่สุดใหญ่ที่สุดฮะ
โอเคค่ะวันนี้นะคะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จัก
ประเทศไทยมีกี่ภาคนะคะนี่ 6 ผ้าค่ะมี 6
ภาคมีภาคอะไรบ้างนะคะมีภาคเหนือวัดตะกู
เอกสีแดงสีสีสีม่วงดีกว่านะคะพักเหนือนะ
คะเพราะอะไรครับภาคอีสาน
ภาคอะไรคะภาคกลาง
การอะไรคะภาคตะวันตก
ภาคอะไรคะภาคตะวันออกภาคอะไรคะภาคใต้ค่ะ
คบภาคนะคะแล้วก็รู้จักว่าเพื่อนบ้านของ
ไทยมีประเทศอะไรคะ
Myanmar ประเทศอะไรคะ
ลาวประเทศอะไรคะและกัมพูชา
ประเทศอะไรคะ
มาเลเซียหมอก็เพื่อนบ้านเรามีกี่ประเทศคะ
เนี่ยมี
4 ประเทศค่ะดีประเทศนะคะชายแดนติดกันนะ
คะ 24 ประเทศโอเคเนาะ
แม่สาดวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักประเทศไทย
แล้วรู้จักประเทศไทยแล้วแล้วก็หมดเวลา
แล้วเราอะไรค่ะแล้วก็ไปเจอกันวีดีโอหน้า
นะคะค่ะแล้วจะหวัดดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย